hi my name's jack
my name's Dale we're gonna tell you
everything you need to know about grow
up in the next three minutes let's go
so bud is back this time he's got a
brand new alien planet to explore
underneath and we're gonna drop down
because of what he's also got it's a
whole new bunch of abilities as well
big knees Bennett loads new abilities to
explore with so balls got football
that's but ball gives you a safe landing
when you're falling from a height switch
yeah but you can also use it deploying
it get yourself up in the end yeah so
I'm gonna use it to get momentum here
boost boom into the glider one yes
awesome there were plants see those
parts down there yeah we've got another
brand new ability in this game to help
you get around this place is worried yes
it's called the flora decks for Alexis
Bud's brand-new brat and in his backpack
it keeps the DNA of all those plants
will be scanned and so all of these
plants here all got crazy names all
crazy descriptions and you can grow them
using the via making the off and your
scanner so from here you just drop seeds
grab hold of this thing and it'll shoot
you into the sky now all of us have
these abilities right now look at books
and shooting games okay
we've also got challenges yep it's all
about challenges challenges where the
world can be found these are actually
given by pod pod who will burn your
character a new character and without
every battle on their neck all the
challenges will actually unlock what
suits you try so my favorite being the
area suit is awesome
which actually gives you another ability
to use the glider twice as fast
we've got other abilities are there bud
suits that come with abilities like
garden one that grows things twice as
big but
pod is Bugs Bunny friend right yeah pure
essence guy gives you a whole new view
of the world you just die I'm sorry we
can show partner this is part of you it
gives you a whole view of the planet
you're from orbit where you can see
everything that you have in the game
where you can set waypoints you can see
where all the offal answer starts first
game where one star plant growing from
the planet up to mom
captain space in this game we have four
new star plants themed in different
areas so we've got a little mushroom e
one over here we have a tropical one
over there got a desert e one over there
and they all you you meet them all to
find the various bits of Mom's ship
parts mom's crashed yeah you need to get
all ship locks back together on the moon
where you fix it and you can be all be
reunited yeah so grow up in three
minutes or so and the grow up is
available on August 16 and it's gonna be
on PC PlayStation 4 and Xbox one